[Music]
what's up guys I'm gonna be showing you
a great money-making method that many of
you are probably already aware of it's a
magic XP money making method you tella
grab Sam Rock whines and now a lot of
you know what that is but the good thing
about right now Sam Rock wines are
selling for almost four point four K
I mean that's insane so for those of you
that don't know how to wear telegraph
lines it's up by taverley so we're gonna
teleport my house is in taverley so I'm
just gonna teleport there you know
portal or you can just teleport falador
and you're going to run over here
it wrote over here get to the skate and
then run straight up I'm sure a lot of
you already know what these what this
method is tell grabbing zemerik whines
how easy it is but also what I'm doing
I'm gonna be alkyne may belong those all
up here to get that additional magic XP
and you don't have to do that but that's
what I like amend you're gonna walk over
here have your law runes and your air
stuff and then till grab zimroth lines
and then wield your staff of fire and
then you start off and while you're
waiting okay so I'm going to do this
load and then I'll be back alright so
something I forgot to tell you guys is
if your pay to play you should bring a
looting bag so then you can run out here
once you have your full inventory of
zamorak lines run out here across the
wilderness stitch step into the
wilderness use your wine on your looting
bag and then click all and then come
back and start lking again and start
telegram and whines all right so I'll be
back when I'm done
alright so I'm done it took about 30
minutes and I didn't get a second full
inventory because it was kind of hard to
find a world that was empty like this
guy kept crashing me so I think I used
all my love ruins but I didn't get all
the damn earth whines so now I don't
have a tumbler at home but I'm ashamed
smell brooklyn bridge and then go to the
GG and i'll sell them and show you guys
what I got all right I'll be back all
right so now I'm in the GE so I'm gonna
go ahead and sell them I could sell them
for a little bit higher but I'm just
gonna assume for the the right-of-way
price so up something for 4,000 each
okay so that's sold right away so with
the Alex and Sam Rock wines it's about
233 234 K and I spent about let's see so
between the nature runes
so the 75301 the nature runes plus the
22,200 from the maple longbows plus the
180 from the LA branch so 106 six eight
zero so 233 minus 106 point six eight
zero so I made about 126 K and that was
in let's see the time so one is 36 K in
30 minutes so that's about 250 K in one
hour so 250 K an hour plus about 35 K
magic experience per hour so I mean
that's that's pretty good additionally
if you just do this without the Alex
that's about 176 K 176 K and 30 minutes
so 176 times 2 so you'll be making 350 K
an hour and that's just for the minimum
price so 300 K an hour I bet you could
make about 400 K now or if you do this
without the Alps and some for the max
price all right so that's all guys stay
tuned for my next video thanks